De nuevo, tendrán que leer y decirme
qué poema piensan que fue escrito por un humano.
Poema 1: Banderas rojas, la razón de hermosas banderas. / Y el blasón.
Blasones de banderas / Y materiales. / Razones para lucir materiales. (...)
Poema 2: Un ciervo herido salta más alto, / He oído al narciso. /
He oído la bandera hoy / He oído al cazador decir; /
No es más que el éxtasis de la muerte / Y luego es casi irrefrenable. (...)
Muy bien, tiempo.
Levanten la mano si piensan que el Poema 1 fue escrito por un humano.
Levanten la mano si piensan que el Poema 2 fue escrito por un humano.
Guau, son muchos más.
Les sorprenderá saber que el Poema 1
fue escrito por la mismísima Gertrude Stein.
Y el Poema 2 fue generado por un algoritmo llamado RKCP.
Pero antes de continuar describiré, simple y rápidamente,
cómo funciona RKCP.
El RKCP es un algoritmo diseñado por Ray Kurzweil,
un director de ingeniería de Google
que cree firmemente en la inteligencia artificial.
Se le proporciona a RKCP un texto fuente,
El RKCP analiza el texto para detectar cómo se usa el lenguaje,
y luego vuelve a generar el lenguaje
que emula al primer texto.
El poema que vimos antes,
el Poema 2, el que todos pensaron que era humano,
fue creado a base de muchos poemas
escritos por la poetisa Emily Dickinson;
analizó la forma en que ella usaba el lenguaje, aprendió el modelo,
y luego volvió a generar un modelo siguiendo la misma estructura.
Pero lo importante a saber de RKCP
es que no conoce el significado de las palabras que usa.
El lenguaje es solo materia prima,
podría ser chino, podría ser sueco,
podría ser todo lo escrito en su muro de Facebook a lo largo del día.
Un idioma no es más que materia prima para la machina.
Y, no obstante, es capaz de crear un poema
que parece más humano que el poema de Gertrude Stein,
y Gertrude Stein es un ser humano.
Aquí hemos hecho, más o menos, una prueba de Turing inversa.
Gertrude Stein, humana, puede escribir un poema
que lleva a pensar a la mayoría de los jueces humanos
que fue escrito por una máquina.
Por lo tanto, según la lógica de la prueba de Turing inversa,
Gertrude Stein es una máquina.
(Risas)
¿Están confundidos?
Pienso que es normal.
Hasta ahora tuvimos humanos que escribían como humanos,
tenemos máquinas que escriben como máquinas,
tenemos máquinas que escriben como humanos,
pero también tenemos, quizá lo que más confunde,
humanos que escriben como máquinas.
¿Qué aprendemos de todo esto?
¿Que William Blake en cierta forma es más humano que Gertrude Stein?
¿O que Gertrude Stein es más autómata que William Blake?
(Risas)
Son preguntas que me he hago
desde hace dos años
y no tengo respuestas.
Pero tengo un montón de ideas
sobre nuestra relación con la tecnología.
Mi primera idea es que, por alguna razón,
asociamos la poesía con el ser humano.
Por eso cuando nos preguntamos: "¿Puede una máquina escribir poesía?"
también preguntamos:
"¿Qué significa ser humanos
y cómo circunscribimos esta categoría?
¿Cómo decidimos quién o qué puede pertenecer a esta categoría?"
Creo que es esencialmente una cuestión filosófica,
que no podemos solucionar con una prueba binaria,
como la prueba de Turing.
Creo que Alan Turing también entendió esto,
y que cuando ideó su prueba allá por los años 50,
lo pensó como una provocación filosófica.
Mi segunda idea es que, si aplicamos la prueba de Turing a la poesía,
en realidad no probamos la capacidad de las máquinas
porque los algoritmos generadores de poesía son bastante simples
y han existido, más o menos, desde los años 50.
En cambio, lo que hacemos con la prueba de Turing en la poesía
es recolectar opiniones sobre el significado de lo humano.
Yo descubrí que,
lo hemos visto hoy más temprano,
decíamos que William Blake es más humano
que Gertrude Stein.
Claro, esto no significa que William Blake
sea en realidad más humano
ni que Gertrude Stein sea más autómata.
Significa simplemente que la categoría de lo humano es inestable.
Esto me ha llevado a comprender
que lo humano no es un hecho rígido, frío.
Más bien, es algo construido con opiniones
y algo que cambia con el tiempo.
Y mi última idea es que la máquina funciona más o menos como un espejo
que refleja cualquier idea humana que le mostramos.
Le mostramos a Emily Dickinson
y nos devuelve Emily Dickinson.
Le mostramos a William Blake
y eso es lo que emula.
Le mostramos a Gertrude Stein
y crea en base al estilo de Gertrude Stein.
Más que cualquier otra tecnología,
la máquina es un espejo que refleja una idea del humano que le mostramos.
Estoy seguro de que muchos de Uds. habrán oído mucho recientemente
sobre la inteligencia artificial.
Y el centro de la conversación
es si podemos crearla.
¿Podemos crear una máquina inteligente?
¿Podemos crear una máquina creativa?
Parece que nos preguntamos sin cesar:
¿Podemos crear una máquina semejante a un humano?
Pero hasta ahora hemos visto
que lo humano no es un hecho científico,
sino una idea armoniosa y siempre cambiante
que cambia con el tiempo.
Cuando empecemos a debatir las ideas
de una inteligencia artificial en el futuro,
no solo deberíamos preguntarnos:
"¿Podemos construirla?"
También deberíamos preguntarnos:
"¿Qué idea de lo humano desearíamos ver reflejada en nosotros?"
Esta es una idea esencialmente filosófica
que no puede responderse solo con software,
sino que requiere un momento de reflexión existencial de la especie.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)